hello and welcome to slice from here
Thorpe Park
coming up thrill-seeking technology we
find out what it takes to build a roller
coaster roses are red violets are blue
but hang on I'm not compatible with news
we look at one dating websites
experiment on its users Google Grass we
meet the student who filmed his entire
graduation day on gas and you haven't
seen the last of us in this week's games
review most of you will have had a go on
a scary roller coaster at some point but
how much do you know about the
technology that goes into making one
well it's all about taming the laws of
physics as Katie Spencer found out this
week stomach-churning drops and Heights
that can take your breath away
advances in technology mean our theme
parks are getting even scarier 3d
software now allows designers to try out
a ride before a single rail is laid
and linear synchronous motor technology
like that used at Sweden's project helix
is making everything faster it can
propel a person from naught to 70 in
just two seconds but the perfect ride
isn't just about extreme engineering
anything above 5g then you get this
sensation which is called G lock which
is a gravity induced loss of
consciousness which is very troubling
for a fighter pilot but experienced at a
theme park only for a brief few seconds
it can actually be quite safe so I think
theme parks are incredibly safe places
to experience these limitations of the
human body unpleasant as it might at
times feel it's a thrill we can't get
enough of
2013 was a great year for many of the
UK's theme parks attendance figures for
Alton Towers shot up by 4 percent on the
year before two two and a half million
at Legoland Windsor visitors increased
by two and a half percent and thought
park recorded an 11 percent attendance
increase having fun it's big business
the owner of many of the UK's biggest
attractions Merlin Entertainments has an
annual turnover of over a billion pounds
but engineering the perfect thrill is in
itself a costly process going way beyond
the initial build and most big theme
parks sensor technology has become
equally important continuously running
to ensure customers stay scared but safe
we're very reactive so any problems we
like an emergency service we come on to
the park error message will be displayed
on the voids we come over and then we
diagnose the fault and rectify any
issues with advances in technology set
to really test our thrill-seeking limits
the biggest challenge is figuring out
just how far we can push ourselves
before it stops being pleasurable Katie
Spencer Sky News well now I'm joined by
a man who actually advises some theme
parks on how to make their rides even
scarier Justin give Anna [ __ ] the
founder of the European coaster club
thanks for joining us now you and I are
about to have a go on a ride here this
warm and with the roller coasters like
this what what are the typical tricks
and features that make them really
elicit fear in the people that ride them
well one of the great things about this
particular ayat is you're allowed a lot
of access into the ride you see the ride
around us now most rides they separate
the riders from the ride itself so you
never get to actually see the riders
hatch before you ride it but here as
you're going towards the right you get
to see the people riding it you get to
see the screen play their screens see
their faces absolutely so before you've
even ridden it you've heard the opinions
of the people who are riding it already
okay what about the height and the speed
well one of the great things about this
particular ride is it starts off with a
hundred and twenty four upside-down drop
which is just amazing and it s some
really nice g-forces it has a 3G section
just here behind us here where you'll
feel three times as heavy
fanta 3G yeah your feet might single if
you're lucky let's get it over and done
with them for a winner
no probably two let's go how you feeling
I'm feeling wonderful about you more
importantly one of the main ones is most
people when they get on a roller coaster
specially for the first time will close
their eyes this is a big mistake because
what will happen is your brain will make
it up as soon as your body goes through
of emotions your body what your brain
will go all we're doing this and make it
worse don't close your eyes look around
relax for many years exactly how far the
body can be questioned and they don't
tend to go near that limit but what's
happening is mice get faster and tall
all the time every year we say the main
factor is the
what do we love being so scared I think
a lot of us in front of desks all day
and just think about image thank you for
showing me in form very afraid
you're watching stripe coming up
Safety's for the glass photo but first
now they say matters of the heart are
never easy to spare a thought the online
daters you found themselves at the
center of an experiment this week well
one in four relationships now start
online but if you'd have headed to
OkCupid looking for someone who shares
your interests ambitions and desires
well you may have been disappointed
after OkCupid founder confessed to
carrying out a few experiments
despite will the bother that Facebook
ended up in recently after it admitted
to playing around with people's feeds to
see if it could change people's moods in
a blog called we experiment on human
beings Christian rudder the founder of
OkCupid made a confession from the heart
saying the site as an experiment had
lied to users about their compatibility
with other singles now the site uses a
special algorithm to determine two
people's suitability as a couple based
on common interests but it deliberately
changed the results of the algorithm to
tell some users who were incompatible
but they were in fact highly compatible
sounds bad right
but OkCupid say people were then much
more likely to interact Asura's
its founder says it showed that the mere
myth of compatibility works just as well
as the truth in another study the site
removed all users photos to see how it
would effect interactions and they
claimed people were quicker to respond
to first messages and exchange contact
information more quickly naughty or nice
well mr. Radha has been reasonably
unrepentant saying guess what everybody
if you use the Internet you're the
subject of hundreds of experiments at
any given time on every site that's how
websites work while some users have
called it creepy it's certainly food for
thought that perhaps online dating is
making some of us a little too
judgmental you're watching spike coming
up the holy grail of batteries to stop
your smartphone stresses there are some
moments you wish you could hang on to
forever
so top marks to the student who filmed
his entire graduation day on Google
glass this week graduation Day 2014
a day for pulling up socks and Chucky
and ties for suit jackets and tic tacs
journaling nerves along the dual
carriageway hoping you won't get carried
away on this big day Google glass and
they were amazing as a piece of
technology but there is more to them
than this intuitive thrill of being able
to film what you are seeing you re-watch
an experience and you can immerse
yourself in what you were doing who you
are with and I feel like this this more
conscious slowed down appreciation of
your experience is something that's
actually neglected in in most modern
technology so I think the reason it was
a big deal for me to wear the Google
glasses to my graduation it's because
traditionally these first-person cameras
have been used in adventure sports and
and extreme sports whereas a graduation
is a more emotional event and when you
merge technology with a personal
experience like this it just feels a bit
more earnest and it does feel more
special the only problem is that we we
as people do tend to be overpowered by
technology so when you go to a concert
you look in the front row everyone's got
their camera phones out and I think that
whilst technology is very good at
capturing what
we see an experience the actual first
person being there in the flesh that
that's unparalleled so whilst I do hope
that you know we were able to integrate
Google glass into more special occasions
I just hope it doesn't detract from the
actual experience itself I wrote a poem
to go the video and I meant those words
I was and I was moved when I wrote the
poem myself because it was all it was
all from the heart waiting for the
Charles name to be read aloud like
reading their name of the school
newsletter except this time any better
when you combine that with first-person
visuals so that people could actually
see what I was seeing that adds a whole
different dimension in when you do that
I think you just enter a whole different
realm of in a very powerful very moving
story talent II do I think that everyone
will be wearing Google glasses in the
next few years I think the answer is
probably yes
but I would hope that that doesn't then
mean that memories become the currency
of social media and hopefully the
thousands of experiences with fun into
some great light at the end of the
tunnel the audience like coming up we're
going rogue in our games review but
first here's a roundup of anything you
might have missed this week Google is
trying to master the secrets of the
human body the baseline study will
collect anonymous genetic and molecular
information from 175 people to create a
clear picture of a healthy human being
volunteers will wear contact lenses with
sensors in designed to measure glucose
levels it's hoped the project could help
detect conditions like heart disease in
its early stages twitter has blocked an
account that publishes leaks from the
russian government at Boalt eye which is
similar to the u.s. group Anonymous has
7,000 followers and despite the Russian
ban can still be seen in other countries
last month Twitter said it wouldn't
censor accounts if the Kremlin asked
them to researchers in the US have been
working on a new type of battery which
could make your phone last three times
longer a team at Stanford University say
they've taken a big step towards
designing a pure lithium anode that's a
specific part of a battery using lithium
in a nose has been difficult in the past
some researchers call it the Holy Grail
ed sheeran has become the first British
star to sign up to a new Facebook app
which can only be used by the rich and
famous the singer-songwriter has joined
the service called mentions which is
currently available only in America the
app is supposed to bring celebrities
closer to fans by letting them respond
to comments about them on the site now
time for something to fulfill your
competitive edge
Cameron Robinson has this week's games
review the Last of Us remastered is can
have it sirens it's a brand new
remastered version of arguably last
year's best game you play as this chap
called Joel basically the whole world
has become infected by this cordyceps
fungus and this is the fungus which
infects kind of the brain of the people
and then you know these horrible growths
kind of spread out and spread spores
everywhere and it spreads the infection
but also drives everyone a bit insane so
it's kind of like a zombie game but it's
got an incredible story between you the
main character Joel and this younger
character Ellie who you're kind of
looking after what is new in the
remastered version well it's replaced
ation for the graphics look much better
susan improved lighting the biggest
difference there was the frame rate so
it runs at 60 frames per second says it
gives you a much smoother experience it
also comes with all the additional
content so it's like the Ultimate
Edition all packaged together if you
have played it to death on your ps3 that
while the visuals are better it was
already a great looking game so whether
or not it's worth getting four that is
up to you but if you've never played it
there's never been a better time to
really have a crack at the Last of Us
with the remastered version
so rogue legacy is a really fun to
Deeside scrolling slashing game that you
can get on their Steam on the PC an
awesome Mac as well it's a lots of ways
to player you start off as a as a knight
and there's a castle and inside this
castle are like traps and bad guys which
you need to fight your way through and
as you fight through you can get you
know runes which give you different
abilities and you can collect gold which
you can then use to buy other equipment
all the kind of standard things you have
in a game like this but the difference
is when you die your character is dead
but then you get to choose to the
players next and you get to choose from
basically your characters children so
you kind of keep your family line going
throughout the game and that really
gives you a reason to kind of keep going
because all your abilities are stuff
carryover it's a really hard game you
die along it's a great game you can
easily spend hours and hours playing
welcome to the areas of Michigan violet
you are an assault reconnaissance
extraction specialist gamers have been
waiting for farfel for quite a while it
was teased that maybe three or four
years ago but it's finally here what is
it well it's a massively multiplayer
online game maybe a little bit like
World of Warcraft one of those games
except it's all sci-fi you play either
first-person so can it inside the body
or third choice or the camera behind you
kind of run around this whole world with
lots of other people who are also online
now it's a bit like some other games
that come out recently but the art style
is something that's really kind of
standing out it's kind of sell shady
that looks really pretty and the biggest
thing about this game though biggest
thing is it's free so you could download
this on your PC right now and play it
without spending a penny obviously you
can buy stuff in-game and that's how
it's gonna hopefully be profitable and
make its money but it's been completely
free massively multiplayer online
experience that's looking pretty great
back in 1997 I remember really fondly
playing to death this demo of Abe's
Oddysee and this game is back 17 years
later and old world new and tasty
there's a remastered version another
remastering of this classic game an
original version you'd move along one
scene and then it would change because
that was kind of the limitations of the
console we were playing on but now it's
all one big long progression and you so
you run through sideways through these
beautifully detailed and drawn worlds
but the story is really quite adorable
it's pretty dark but it's quite amusing
as well your am this character a band
you work in this meat processing plant
and you find out at the beginning that
your species is the next on the chopping
block as it were so you decide to escape
and you have to avoid combat really
you're very vulnerable one hit and
you're dead
so it's all about solving puzzles trying
to save your inhabitants but it's also
got this great kind of slapstick humor
all the way through so it's great to see
this old game being brought back now to
PlayStation 4 thanks Cameron that's it
for this week don't forget you can catch
up with all the waking tech stories all
week on Chinese dry pad smartphone apps
Chinese comm do you go next time bye bye